let's talk about u.s
u.s new home sale prices
fell 5.9 in april after big
march gain go to page four on real
estate let's talk a little bit of
business here
before we go back to other topics that
we got just more good news for the
economy guys
yes u.s new home sales fell 5.9
in april after a big march gained this
is an ap story sales of new homes fell a
bigger than expected 5.9 percent
a drop that analyst blamed in part on
rising home prices the median price of a
new home sold
last month was 372 000 up from 11.4
of march while the average price of home
sold in april
was a record 435. 8.7
up from march it's insane how much this
thing's going up just a month this is
not a year over year this is a month
economist said the declines in part
reflected the headwinds
presented by surging costs for lumber
and supply chain restraint and obtaining
such products as new appliances but
analysts said that demand for homes
remaining strong sales should continue
to be
robust in the coming months new home
sales
fell in every region of the country in
april except the west
which posted a 7.9 percent increase
sales were down 13.7 percent
in the northeast and fell 8.3 percent
midwest
and 8.2 percent in south so everything
fell except for the west
thoughts well where where do i come from
jersey and where am i now florida like
everybody else
yeah they have priced us out there's no
businesses they're literally not
open they shut us down i was held
political hostage for two years with
everybody else
to feed the ambitions of a far-left
tyrannical government
and they've bankrupted people they have
uh do you know give you a perfect
example all right it's not it's not a
lot of money but give you a perfect
example
of how stupid how how moronic
my area of the country is ran do you
know what it cost me
to leave my apartment in jersey city and
then drive out of the state
down uh through delaware to drive down
to how much what do you think it cost me
to get out of my state to get out of
your city leave jersey
bridges and total okay 20 bucks okay you
mean just
in tolls and what do you mean and yeah
yeah what are they called paying for
just tall it's tall talls 100 bucks okay
it was 26
okay you know what it took me what the
cost was from delaware to florida
twenty six dollars two dollars and fifty
cents get out you didn't take the
tournament it was
twenty five i took ninety nine it was 26
to leave my
state one of the smaller states on the
map
250 to go the rest of the coast and
that's a long drive by the way
do you know how much it costs to go over
a bridge
in new jersey to go into new york
eighteen dollars every time they go you
would know the answer to that that's
right
the the the bridge master himself the
well he shuts the bridges down though he
doesn't you know you don't go over his
bridge
the uh do you know what it cost to get
on a beach in jersey
they pay you have to pay to get on a
beach it's 14 for the day
they own outside the bridge is in the
air
they own the air they own the beach they
own your backyard
why every day i was there every minute i
was in brooklyn and jersey
i felt like i was failing an idiot test
every second i stayed there i felt like
i was failing
an idiot test and it's the worst feeling
in the world because the people
are the best people on earth they're
hard working they're tough they're good
nature the food's amazing the culture is
amazing
half hour in new york out of philly you
got you got the short everything you
ever want is right there
and they they they're pricing everybody
out we're leaving
we're three years in a row three years
in a row jersey leaves the country leads
the country
in in expatriates we're emigrating out
in in uh trump's in trump's third year
he had a record uh unemployment low
unemployment right i believe it was
three and a half three and a half
percent do you know what jerseys
do you know what jersey's contribution
to that was
we lost 250 000 jobs jersey lost 250 000
in a in
in the most record employment of all
time wow jersey
lost job we had 250 000 more people go
on employment that's phil murphy and
he's gonna moonwalk into re-election so
everybody's leaving it's a hopeless
hopeless hopeless feeling
million dollar homes to pay 17
property taxes it's insane what's pr
what
in bergen county 17 property tax there's
no way it's 17. look it up it's nuts
i pull it up 17 property taxes dude they
they get you they don't
they capped it like which and then so
they cap it at three percent right yeah
but what they do is they do a mandatory
reevaluation like every three years okay
so they'll come up to you
and you'll have like a little
three-bedroom ranch in bergen county
yeah
and they'll come up and they'll bergen
county bergen county yeah and they'll
they'll say congratulations man you got
a million and a half dollar property
this is what your taxes are what you're
saying and it's like whoa whoa
what so do you want to buy it for a
million and a half i'll sell it to you
no no go ahead
so when they capped it at three percent
all they did is just triple the price of
everybody's uh
of everybody's homes it was nuts man
2.18 which is higher than most places
type and highest property tax in america
highest property tax in america
just do a problem just do the highest
overall tax burden man i believe
if i remember correctly the pew
institute the pew institute did a study
and essentially 43 cents out of every
dollar in new jersey goes to taxes
43 out of every dollar earned so you
only get new jersey and illinois have
the highest effective property tax in
the country yeah
highest profit and by the way here's
what's so funny about what do you get
for it
what are you doing we got we get we live
in jersey you get potholes bro
like what do you get nothing nothing you
want to talk about a scam
somebody who's running a freaking scam
somebody who's the the the port
authority of new york and new jersey
all right it's 18 to go through the
tolls it's 18
you've been at the hudson tunnel you've
been you've it that's 17 lanes
20 cars deep 18 each
24 7 365. all right
they're telling they trying to tell us
that that the uh
that that the transit fund is is
bankrupt
they don't have any money they're
pulling in 300 billion dollars in tolls
annually
no money don't know where it went what
huh
and nobody can check it because it's a
slush fund it's a slush fund it's the
new york and new jersey
port authority so when you try to do an
audit new york says oh jersey's got the
money then you try to audit jerseys
you're like oh new york's got the money
it where's it going into the ether and
everybody's got to go through easy pass
which is owned by xerox okay so what's
your
what's taking what you're saying right
now what you're saying right now is
you're specifically to one area
saying that real estate in northeast
obviously you're not optimistic about it
long term of where it's at right now
you're not optimistic especially because
the city is going why is
west doing well west sales are up
real estate real estate west real estate
is up and west by the way not a small
number it was a high number that that
everything else was down
except for the west it said you know new
home sales uh
fell in every region of the country in
april except the west
which posted a 7.9 percent increase
sales were down 13.7 percent northeast
83 in the midwest and 8.2 percent in
in the south you don't need cities
anymore pat you don't need city
infrastructure
what do you mean by that you don't need
cities anymore it's an antiquated model
now i mean think about it if you if you
are the type of person if you're a
freelancer
if you're a developer if you're in
software if you're any part of the new
gig economy
you don't need to travel into a hub
location
go 80 floors up work for goldman and
then
you know be there one-on-one for these
meetings now there's always going to be
something
said for doing business one-on-one and
having these interactions having these
conversations
but there's a lot of deadline driven
jobs now that you can do from anywhere
if you're a software developer you can
do it from aspen and then go skiing and
then you can be in malibu the next day
and do it there
if you have a computer and if you have
an internet connection
you can be at work no matter where you
are so why would you pay these taxes for
proximity to the city
now if enough people do that let's say
even 10 percent of people
are able to digitally commute and
digitally work what does that do to the
ecosystem
that the entire city is built on what's
that due to the pizzeria
that's down the block that services
these these uh these buildings what's
that do to the dry cleaners
what's that do to every single other
runoff industry
right what does that do if you take 12
million people in new york
and they say it it bumps up to 15
million during the day and then it's
eight million at night so new york city
doubles between eight eight and eight
right
people coming in people coming out what
happens if those eight million stay home
now you've got the highest real estate
in the in the country you're paying 32
dollars a square foot you're already
charging five dollars a slice
what are you gonna sell seven dollar
pizza how do you make that up
and then you talk about real estate you
got real estate investment trusts we
don't want to get like crazy deep into
it but
real estate investment trusts they're
ruining everything you you have people
who can
why do you say the reits are ruining
everything because there's no
disincentive
there's no disincentive to sell there's
no disincentive to adjust your market
so you can sit there and have an empty
building
and he said andy send the text to kai
andy driscolli send the text to
310-340-1132-310-340-1132
andy sells cars in bergen county and he
says he's right send a text to
cairo quick we're going to call you up
go keep going what up andy yeah so real
estate investment trust they destroyed
new jersey right
so these large massive conglomerates
come in
and they can only rent out half of their
half their building
okay whatever capacity but they but they
rent it out at the top of the market
and then people buy into their package
of properties
that are priced at however many units
at that price so they're they're making
all of their money in the trust sales
so they don't have to actually adjust to
the marketplace and lower prices so
eight million
so like everybody's leaving new york
right now everybody you saw the letter
from the guy who owns the stand new york
is dying blah blah blah blah
so you would assume prices would go down
prices have not gone down because they
don't have to
they don't have to adjust to the market
they're they're making money they can
take the loss
and they're making a ton of money off of
off of selling the trust on the backside
so they've they've literally double
insulated themselves they've cornered
the market
what do you think about that what do you
think about what he's saying and what do
you think about what we just read about
with real estate sales
uh well number one first and foremost
gerard you're gonna be okay bro no
i just want you to know that you're
you're you're you're fired up about new
jersey
we want to take the team it's time for
the t to go into the harbor baby
t to harbor time gerard is on one right
now and if i lived in new jersey over
the last two years i'd probably be upset
like him
as well but i've been living in florida
and in texas so i got a little perkier
demeanor than our friend
gerard right here things are going to be
okay the sweet taste of freedom
exactly you're down in florida now let
the new jersey keep jersey in jersey
i've noticed that everyone down there
the boy leaves yours let the boy
the boy leave jerseys tell us i mean we
were talking about
new home sales i assume we we we
basically just discovered everything we
need to know about new jersey in the
last 20 seconds
um i think you just gave me a nosebleed
all right you're gonna be
okay you're in florida now let's go
we've got your muscles if you bring some
tissue for our body here
keep going i'm gonna blew an ammunition
throw it through it come on we can catch
we got athletes over here um i don't
even remember what the hell the topic
goes up but
what i will say is that if you missed
the boat
on buying a house just pump the brakes
they don't need to buy right now
okay this is like basically trying to
get in on bitcoin at 60
and then uh six months later you find
out that bitcoin's at 35 or 40.
if you miss the boat on trying to buy a
house in most of the country
just pump the brakes in rent okay on the
flip side commercial real estate might
be a great place
to look into because commercial place uh
commercial buildings are empty right now
so great time to look into commercial
real estate
for deals for residential for deals for
residential it is a
seller's market agree yeah what i
disagree is that
you think it's it's a bubble that's
going to come back down i don't think it
is for a commercial
you don't think it's going to come back
down i don't you don't think price is
going to come back down look at the
look at the price there's a part of what
he's saying
that he's not wrong the part that
you may have somebody opposing argument
to you is the fact that rates are going
to go
up absolutely when the rates do go up
the only difference that's going to
happen
is the fact that your payment is going
to be a lot higher so rather than paying
three grand for mortgage payment you're
gonna you may be paying forty five
hundred bucks
forty two hundred bucks you may even end
up paying six thousand dollars a month
for the you know
some kind of a loan you're getting but
there's a big argument right now being
made that prices are not going to be
going down
and there's i'm sure there's a big
argument that prices are going to go
down
yeah you're right but but i'm not a
realtor so i'm not even a realtor that's
saying this to you what i'm saying to
you is there's an argument right now
i guarantee you our realtor friends are
telling us it's a great time to buy
they're they're going to carry them
that's what they do they're saying it's
a great thing i'm calling you i'm
calling you just like the stock market
enthusiasts are telling you it's a great
time to invest in the market
andy pay your phone bill buddy
he's got property taxes
this is the the arrogance the arrogance
to the left over here just like ah you
didn't build that
okay he just paid his phone bill hey how
you doing andy andy fine and dandy
so andy good man so you selling cars
what kind of cars you selling in jersey
we sell jeep chrysler hey
man i got myself a jeep compass bro
oh yeah yeah route 18 jeep did a good
job there you must be your competitors
yeah definitely so so so you you heard
you heard gerard say a bunch of things
about bergen count bergen county
what can you tell us about what's going
on in jersey and why are you still
there well here's what i'll tell you
it's it's a it's a great answer actually
i'm not
living in bergen county okay i work in
bergen county community from
pennsylvania
new york commute 45 minutes to get there
interesting we don't know why but
in the last year yeah for some reason
covet hit and all of a sudden we're
selling more cars for higher prices than
ever before obviously supply and demand
cars used cars but it's called the
stimulus check you are
begging to pay over msrp
it's a fluent area so me
trying to buy a home closer to work has
been a fail because
of what everything he's saying he's
exactly right
dude can you can you unpack that what do
you mean by that you've had a hard time
buying a home because
because what because everybody's over
bidding because people are willing to
pay more
yeah i wouldn't even look on the jersey
line my whole family's from jersey
my father you know moved to new york 20
30 years ago rather 36 years ago
but um yeah i wouldn't even look on the
other side of the jersey line because i
already know
the taxes it's expensive you know
looking in a
40-50 mile radius because i'm already
commuting
45-50 miles to work from new york
is a better bet than buying
let me ask you this and i'm gonna you
can chime in as well once he's done
why are people staying in jersey or
are there a lot of conversations maybe
you're having with your family where
people are saying look andy we're
thinking about leaving this place and
they're saying we may move to
dot dot dot so why aren't people leaving
and if they are were they looking at
most of my family you know older aunts
uncles you know grandpa yeah
they all they already moved to florida
they already moved to florida
my dad just went to florida to visit his
sister
and that's what happens you know every
few years those are the retirees but
that's nothing new
old people moving to florida is not
breaking news but young people
is different well now they're charging
us to leave
18 now what's happening is as far as
who's
who's not leaving and why they're not
leaving um
mainly i would say that because the
people that are
either renting homes have kicked their
rentees out to then
sell the home for an overprice you know
an overpriced value
or vice versa the people that were
living in their homes
can now rent them or split them up and
rent them because prices are so high
that now it becomes
a secondary or a third you know income
so
why leave if you own a home and you can
sell it for more
or rent it out rather um
there's so much money being made in the
in the like you always say i listen to
you guys all the time there's more real
estate agents than homes i mean it's
it's absolutely just ridiculous and and
the housing market
and the car market and what's been going
on
especially in that area it's just a
proof of that it's just proof
people are literally paying more than
ever before we're making the same amount
and more
record selling months month after month
after month
on less units because of the you know
supply demand
they're doing this on purpose andy
they're doing this this is a plan
patrick said it you said it before if
the government wants the market to move
in a direction it has ways to do it
how many times in the last two years
have you heard build back better build
back better
build back better you will own nothing
and be happy yeah you will
davos right bill de blasio
has said his biggest regret is allowing
private property in manhattan he thinks
the government
should be the real estate agent
of new york pull up uh affordable
housing kai if you can
pull up the map of affordable housing in
manhattan pull up the map of government
assistant housing
in manhattan it's the entire island
the entire island has some sort of
subsidized housing
well we all know in new york the rent is
too damn high it is and why
and why that's the problem why
the entire island is affordable housing
the entire
island is subsidized housing that's all
government subsidized property right
there that's guaranteed money
okay so when i go back to the reits they
got guaranteed section 8 housing that's
paid
up front by the government to the real
estate
all right up to whatever market value is
so there's no incentive if people leave
to lower the rates they set the price
the government pays the price
and then the rest of the building is
empty and they use those units
to sell on as part of their as part of
their their reit package
so the middle guy in the middle of the
everyday person we're a schmuck
and why do you why don't you leave why
why doesn't anybody leave anywhere
like why why are people still living in
afghanistan like i don't know man like
this home
it's home you don't want to leave your
home are you too good for your home
no i don't
you know 30 seconds of fame and thank
you guys because i want to tell you this
is
very important to me i've been listening
to you
adam everyone on the show for the last
six months
i worked all the way through the
pandemic at the dealership
right now instead of buying a home the
last
120 days i've been doing as much
research as possible
into crypto into investing
making sure that i have my money away
for that when
when adam i agree the market does
dip that's when i'm gonna capture some
sort of deal but i am definitely not
buying a house anytime soon
smart man andy market i can't pay over
my sticker i just don't see it
say that much love to you man much love
to you we're glad we had you on buddy
take care of yourself good having you on
take care bye bye bye
all right there you go good so another
jersey story right there
yeah to hear what you said so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you